لكن كيف يمكن ان تؤثر هذه الاتهامات
الاخيره على فرص ترامب في السباق نحو
البيت الابيض هذا سؤال مهم يقول خبراء ان
الملاحقه القضائيه للترامب ستسمح لمنافسه
داخل الحزب الجمهوري لاسيما حاكم
ونائبه السابق في توجيه سهام الانتقادات
بحقه حيث سيجد منافسه ترامب الفرصه سانحه
للترويج بان ترامب وهو المرشح الاوفر حظا
وفقا لاستطلاعات الراي حتى الان غير جدير
بتمثيل الجمهوريين لمنافسه بايدن في
انتخابات 20 24 يرى مراقبون انه على الرغم
من ان الاتهامات التي تلاحق ترامب لن
تمنعه من الترشح لكنها ستمثل نقطه تحول في
حملته للانتخابات التمهيديه ومع اشتعال
الصراع الانتخابي مبكرا يبدو ان راندي
سنتيس هو الذي اظهر الدعم في تصريحاته
الاخيره للترامب لن يفوت الفرصه للنيل من
غريبه شانا جارديان استاذه العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه سيراكيوز قالت ان روندي
سنتيس سيستغل المتاعب القانونيه للترامب
في جذب اكبر عدد ممكن من مؤيده لكسب ثقتهم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات